تشعر بالاتصال
بالسلاحف البحرية عندما تسبح معها ،
فأنت تعلم أنه أمر لا يصدق ، إنها
تجربة لا تصدق حقًا
لمرة واحدة في العمر بالنسبة لنا ، إنها سحرية
هنا ، أعني أن الشواطئ
لم تكن جميلة أبدًا  في حياتي ، رأيت المياه كما في
إليوثيرا ، إنها حقًا واحدة من
أجمل الأماكن على الخطة ، أعتقد أنني
كاثرين وهذا ديفيد ونحن
من تامبا فلوريدا ونحن هنا
نتطوع مع Earth Watch للمساعدة في
البحث عن البحر
لطالما أحببت السلاحف البحرية أثناء
نشأتي ، لطالما جمعت السلاحف
ولأنها من الأنواع المهددة بالانقراض ، فإن
مشاهدة الأرض هي حقًا الطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكننا من خلالها الاقتراب منها ،
لقد كنا فقط على اطلاع على موقع مراقبة الأرض في
انتظار  من أجل هذه
الرحلة ، يرجى الاشتراك في رحلة واحدة
لطيفة ، فقط قم بإجراء تنظيف بسيط ، اسمي
أنابيل بروكس وأنا
العالم الرئيسي للمسار في C Tails في
مشروع جزر البهاما ومع Earth Watch
لدينا متطوعون ذلك  ادخل
وساعدني في هذا المجال ، لذا فهم موجودون بالفعل
يساعدوننا في التقاط السلاحف حتى
نتمكن من جمع البيانات التي
نحتاجها للإجابة على بعض
الأسئلة البيولوجية والبيئية المهمة حقًا لي
أيضًا بمجرد إحضار السلاحف إلى
الشاطئ  بقياس صدفتهم ،
نقيس رأسها ، فنحن نلتقط
صورًا للسلاحف البحرية أيضًا ثم نضع علامة عليها
بحيث في المستقبل إذا استعدنا أسر
هذا الفرد ، فسنعرف بالضبط من
هم وكم نمت وكيف
إنهم يتطورون بحيث يعطينا
قدرًا هائلاً من المعلومات كما
ترون السلحفاة ، من الصعب حقًا أننا على
متن قارب ونحن نوعًا ما نتجول
في منطقة نعتقد
أنه سيكون هناك عدد كبير من البحار
تكتشف السلاحف أن سلحفاة بحرية ستتبعها في
القارب وسيقفز شخص واحد من القارب
وسيسبح لمحاولة
الإمساك بالسلاحف البحرية.
مما اعتقدت حقا
أن الأفضل هو عندما ال  عين تحتك مباشرة
وأنت تسبح فوقهم وأنت تسبح
تمامًا كما
تسبح السلحفاة معًا ويبدو الأمر كما لو أنني
لا أريد إيقاف هذا مثل نعم ، دعنا
نستمر في النوم هكذا ولكن
بعد ذلك  تعتقد أن أنابيل ، كما
تعلم ، بحاجة إلى مساعدتنا في أبحاث الأستاذ ،
لذا يجب أن أحتاج إلى اللحاق بك الآن
حسنًا
[موسيقى]